[Music]
humor relate directly to positive
Judaism because humor is one of the 24
strengths in the category in the
inventory of strengths and
characteristics and we know that humor
which makes us laugh and we desire to be
around people who are funny because it
raises our senses of positive emotion
and that adds a lot of value the US Open
and Yom Kippur generally fall during the
same season of time Yom Kippur is the
Day of forgiveness it happens in the
very early fall and the US Open happens
in the late summer early fall and it
just so happened that one year the men's
final and Yom Kippur happened on the
same exact day and so this child said of
his father dad you know I can't miss the
US Open it's the most important tennis
match of the entire year and the father
said well that's what video recordings
are for and the child said you mean we
can tape the ohm keep or we can always
choose to live with a pessimistic
mindset a lot of people ask you know
Judaism and positivity can they sync
together and they can despite the fact
that individuals have faced
anti-semitism and oppression and there
have been many times in Jewish history
like the pogroms when Jewish individuals
and Jewish communities were oppressed
and that is true for lots of different
groups but at the core of religious
thought it is about resilience and it is
about hope it's about joy it's about
positive living it's about spirituality
deepening relationships and seeking to
have a positive impact on one's life on
their community and their family and in
the world hatikvah is the jewish
national anthem Hatikvah means the hope
and at the core of the Jewish mindset
for 3,000 years has been a
I'll tell you a story about hope which
is attributed to the mug Eid of Dubin of
Megiddo Dube nam tells a story of a king
who had a perfect diamond and that king
loved this diamond and he would marvel
at this diamond every single night
but one day he dropped this diamond and
when he picked it up he noticed that
there was a crack from the crown to the
base of this diamond and the King was
crestfallen him he called out to all of
the master craftsmen in the entire King
to come and see if they could repair
this but one after the other said the
King King once a crack is in a diamond
it cannot be repaired days later a very
humble jeweler came to the palace gates
and said I would like to see the diamond
and the King welcomed him and said
humble jeweller the greatest craftsmen
and all of his land have tried to fix
this diamond and each have said it's
impossible to repair but this humble
jeweler said I would like to have a
chance and so the King gave him the
diamond and under the eyes of a watchful
guard for the next few weeks
this jeweler got to work he returned to
the kingdom and he presented the King
with the diamond and the King took it
out and looked at it and said fool there
was still a crack in my diamond send
this man to the gallows but the humble
jeweler just stood there calmly and said
King turned the diamond over and when
the King turned the diamond over he
noticed that the jeweler had placed two
petals at the crown of the diamond and
together this crack with those petals no
longer was broken but it now formed this
beautiful rose and now the King had a
diamond that was more perfect and more
beautiful than before the moral of this
story is that we can choose any day to
think of our lives as broken
only seeing the cracks but with a little
dose of hope and choosing to be
optimistic we can turn any crack into
petals and to shift the way that we
think about brokenness into perfection
and turn our lives into beautiful
flowers that we get from Judaism and
that we get from wise teachings they
come from Jewish past and Jewish lore
that inspire us to live our lives in the
best way for ourselves for our families
and for others
[Music]